n-b-c walking back it's big story today
that the feds had wired tapped the
phones of the president's personal
attorney Michael Cohen now the story now
has a lengthy correction on top saying
that three senior US officials disputed
that report the correction explains that
Cohen's calls were monitored but not
wiretap big difference and that
investigators didn't actually listen to
his calls
well Fox News has confirmed that at
least one of Cohen's phones was
monitored with a device that records
phone numbers dialed and the length of
those calls and even before by the way
NBC realized its mistake
Giuliani correctly shot down the report
telling The Daily Beast we think it's
going to turn out to be untrue because
it would be totally illegal disclosing a
wiretap is itself a federal felony Wow
well all of this came after Giuliani
emphasized that the Trump team will no
longer sit idly by while Muller's
investigation creeps into every part of
the president's life this started as
collusion with the Russians know right
now they go to obstruction of justice
collusion among the players what they
really trying to do is trap them into
Persia right so let's talk about no way
I'm win are suckers let's get into
today's developments with former White
House press secretary Ari Fleischer
former whitewater deputy independent
prosecutor Saul Eisenberg and former FEC
Chairman Bradley Smith oh god guys we
have so much to get through I want to go
to you first Bradley there was a moment
during the interview this morning with
Rudy Giuliani where he again reiterated
that this was not a campaign
contribution and then he added another
thought that seemed to contradict the
first thought let's watch if we had a
defend this as not being a campaign
contribution I think we could do that
this was for personal reasons
this was the president had been hurt
personally not politically personally so
much and and and the first lady
by some of the false allegations that
one more false allegation six years old
I think he was trying to help the family
and for that the man is being treated
like some kind of villain and I think he
was just being a good lawyer imagine if
that came out on October 15th 2016 yet a
little of the you know last debate with
Hillary Clinton making it go away they
they made this home he didn't even ask
Cohen did it Cohen made it go away he
did his job Bradley do you see my point
there I mean it was all during the
campaign I mean it was all October
whether it was three weeks before the
election or two weeks before the
election I wasn't quite getting that
particular point and whether it makes a
difference in terms of any FEC
violations right well I don't know
exactly you know I can't speak for for
Rudy what he was thinking but the basic
law on this is that many things that can
influence a campaign are not campaign
expenditures so for example if the
candidate thinks hey I'd look great in
that new suit he goes out spends 18
hundred dollars on a suit not a campaign
expenditure how to pay for that was his
personal funds you know if he thinks boy
I'd do better on this grueling campaign
if I had a week at Martha's Vineyard
first not a campaign expenditure
personal expenditure and the rule on
this it's not that something related to
the campaign is a campaign expenditure
it's not to something primarily related
to the campaign is a campaign
expenditure the FEC rejected both those
options it has to be something an
obligation that would not exist but for
the campaign and I think that there's a
strong argument at least from what we
know publicly that a man like Trump
could say look we would have made these
payments celebrities have to make these
kinds of payments you already said yeah
and he would have reasons like his you
know protecting his family protecting
his commercial viability just not
wanting the distraction all of those
things that might have made him do it
The New Yorker has run an article
suggesting he's paid made similar
payments in the past which would suggest
that it's not something pertaining to
his candidate and even stormy Daniels if
we are to believe her said in her sixty
minutes interview that as far back as
2011 she was told not to say anything
about this suggesting that long before
he was a candidate
they did they want to keep this quiet so
I think that there's a very strong
argument that this is not a campaign
contribution and not a campaign spent
expenditure and it really doesn't matter
whether Cohen paid it or Trump aided or
Trump reimbursed Cohen that's not a
campaign expenditure it's not that
because it all go to state of mind then
saw I mean the state of mind of Donald
Trump when he was reimbursing of during
what time frame is that relevant here to
look at this because again the way
Bradley just described it I completely
understand that but the way of course
it's being reported across most of media
today it is you know burn down the house
kind of stuff your reaction well I would
never burn down the house under for this
kind of a campaign law violation
assuming that it is one I mean this is
not the crime of the century it's
relatively small potatoes
Bradley's more of an expert on election
law than I am I've always thought the
test was here is it for the purpose of
influencing the campaign and so I think
it's always going to be a question when
you do something eleven days before the
campaign but it's really ultimately a
fact question and by no means would it
be easy to prove but again in the grand
scheme of things it's relatively minor I
can't imagine any president being
impeached much less prosecuted for a
felony for that it doesn't change the
fact that Rudy isn't really talking
about it
in a very intelligent way and that it's
very dangerous to go on television and
start talking about what your client
said and did Ari I want to play for you
a montage of media comments today about
this wiretap issue let's watch they were
able to get text emails and wiretaps on
his many phone lines leading up to the
raid and continuing and if you're
involved in conspiracy if you're
involved in a crime or if you're
involved as dirty tricks or a cover-up
or an obstruction or trying to if
there's evidence of a crime I don't care
if you're the president's lawyer you're
the skip the same treatment I do you go
to a judge and say I want to listen to
its phone okay well turns out that
didn't happen and you wonder why people
call it fake news
they were positively jubilant too all
day like we're gonna have the recording
so we're gonna be able to listen and
it's qohen and in the President and
they're destroying documents we're just
guessing I mean the speculation about
what the conversation might have been if
Trump actually had a conversation with
Michael Cohen I've never heard anything
like a reaction to this media feeding
frenzy well the whole velocity and
direction of the press is to blame
Donald Trump for everything and that's
been a constant lawyer it's been since
he became a candidate and it's
accelerated since he became president so
when NBC hears about something like this
and they really haven't explained how
and why they got it wrong they just run
with it and then everybody else wants to
run with it too it reminds me still to
this day Laura CNN MSNBC and CBS have
never explained how they put a story on
the air saying multiple sources read a
memo saying that Donald Trump jr. had
advanced notice of the WikiLeaks now
they had to retract that because the
person reading the memo got a date wrong
and the notice was after the WikiLeaks
was aired but they never explained how
they possibly could have all had
multiple sources getting that story
wrong because the threshold is so low
for anti Trump stories and it's hurting
journalism it's one of the reasons
America is splitting into two frankly
where you have people who don't trust
the press don't believe the press and
other people who just hate Donald Trump
it's not healthy for the country to have
the press get it wrong like that yeah by
the way Michael avenatti the attorney
for stormy Daniels we invited him on the
show tonight he declined he said he was
otherwise occupied but he also was out
there saying this is a fact and I've
noticed they're treating him they're
treating him like he's just an objective
analyst whether whether it's about the
law or whether it's about about what
happened and he keeps saying it's a fact
and you see these were journalists going
mmm like stroking their chin it's a fact
of course that wasn't a fact it wasn't a
fact at all you know they're treat they
treat Michael avenatti the same way they
treated Adam press play chef if either
of those two see an affluent anti-trump
they can get on the air instantly and
have no no cynical tough questions asked
Brad they want to go to you on this
other development that we learned today
that the email that Michael Cohen used
to I guess facilitate or finalize the
deal with the payments to Daniel's was a
trump dot-org email does that have any
bearing on this on this case and how it
will be looked at by Muller who we know
and we're gonna get into this next
segment we know can be you know
overzealous and he pushes the boundaries
of the law to get the result that he
wants I mean I'm sorry but it's not the
first time it happened he saw it with
the Blagojevich case so let's let's talk
about that a little bit the Trump org
email they're making a huge deal of this
also in the media tonight of course I
can't say what what mother is gonna do
right but I'd go back to saying look
again if it's not a campaign expenditure
if it wasn't made if it wasn't an
obligation that would have existed that
would not have existed but for the
campaign then it doesn't matter how it
was paid in fact she would expect it not
to be paid with campaign funds you'd
have to come from somewhere else in fact
this is one of the problems or imagine
if the Trump folks had paid for this
with campaign funds and reported this is
a campaign expenditure I can guarantee
you you can bet the farm that a lot of
the same people critical of the
administration now critical of Trump in
the campaign would have filed complaints
alleging that this was an illegal
diversion of campaign funds for personal
use and that's the problem that you have
here that's why I have additional use
doctrine so others they were going to
get them coming or going if he spends
campaign funds they'd say that's you
can't spend campaign funds for that
that's personal if he spends personal
funds they say oh that had to be put to
benefit your campaign and that's illegal
and it can't can't be both so let's move
on to the monitoring of perhaps text
messages who was being texted not not
the content of it but who was being
Texas in the monitoring of Cohen's phone
calls like to whom was he speaking what
number was he speaking to so not the
content but the log of the calls is that
surprising too unusual to you or what
would that indicate that Muller believes
no it's actually a standard opera well
first of all remember the campaign
and stuff is not muddler that's the
southern district so this is a Southern
District issue not a Muller issue but
it's relatively standard operating
procedure and you don't need probable
cause for that it happens in hundreds of
thousands of cases throughout the
country in and by the way on this NBC
thing if NBC had talked to anybody who's
knowledgeable about federal criminal law
and white collar cases they would have
immediately said that can't be right
that story can't be right because as
Giuliani is right about this that's
that's a crime to leak something like
that that is incredibly serious it's
more serious than leaking grand jury
information and I knew the story was it
couldn't be right when I heard it why
didn't they check with with somebody who
actually knows something about federal
criminal law before going with this I
don't understand it district what it
finds saw however if it finds something
in all those documents that they took
from Michael Cohen's various you know
places of residence and anything relates
to Russia or tangential to the Russia
investigation that kicks back to Muller
correct so as a proxy to get information
for Muller right yep you were cynical
you could you could call it a problem
whole operation I am there's nothing
after all this time so I'm a little
cynical about this yeah yeah you're a
former prosecutor so that's what that's
our that's the lines that we draw but we
love each other well I've been on the
defense side longer than I've been on
the prosecution side but you're but
you're right if they're if they come
across something that looks like
evidence of a crime and it's in Muller's
bailiwick it does go back to Muller but
there's really nothing unusual about
trap-and-trace monitoring it's like mail
covers you're just seeing what numbers
are they dialing how many times are they
talk are they talking to this person but
they're not actually getting the content
of the message so if they see that Cohen
after his offices were raided made a
phone call to a white house number they
can you know put the screws on Cohen
said to whom did you speak and
to speak about right he can refuse to
answer or they could try to get someone
they're interviewing at the White House
to answer that question right otherwise
they're not gonna find out what happened
unless they were contemporaneous right
Yeah right right but I can guarantee you
as a general matter they're going to be
putting the screws to Cohen across the
board that's just very obvious from the
way they're conducting this
investigation and the question is what
do they have on him what do they have on
him that has nothing to do and nothing
to do with the president all right yeah
hold on I got to play this for Ari and
then we come back Ari today at the White
House briefing I knew that this was
gonna happen with Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and indeed the press focused right on
well you didn't say you said the
opposite about stormy Daniels let's
watch you explain why the president when
he spoke when he asked you have two
questions reporters a few weeks ago
about $230,000 came to Mike's going to
see to strongly gales why the president
was not truthful with the American
people and what people expect as mayor
Giuliani stated and I'll refer you back
to his comments this was information
that the president didn't know at the
time but eventually learned how are the
American people to trust or believe what
is said here or what is set by the
president we give the very best
information that we have at the time
circle May 3rd on your calendar because
this is the day that we will look back
on in this briefing where Sarah Sanders
made it so painfully clear that she has
lost credibility with the American
people with the reporters in that room I
think it's hilarious for CNN to talking
about
losing credibility with the American
people right there that that really
struck us stuck out for me Ari what
about that with Sarah Sanders I mean she
she goes out and says what she knows
I thought that was a low blow cheap shot
by that CNN political director it's
tough and look that's a hard job as
especially hard when you're giving
incomplete information as the press
secretary and if the incomplete
information is given to you by the
president you're particularly vulnerable
and I think that is what happened here
look when the president was on Air Force
One and when Michael Cohen answered the
question about payments and he said the
Trump campaign of the Trump Organization
they were being precisely accurate
but they both omitted crucial
information Sarah when she briefed the
press then and she said no payments by
the president either Sarah went one step
too far and over spoke or the president
gave her information that turned out to
be incorrect I don't know which of those
two is the fact but the timetable Sarah
is a hundred percent right it is
entirely reasonable for the president
not to have known with specificity what
Michael Cohen did in October of 2016 but
he learned it later
that makes all kinds of sense in fact I
would be surprised if that's the usual
routine between Michael Cohen and Donald
Trump Michael Cohen cleans it up doesn't
fill him in on all the details and the
presents happy not to know all the
details and that probably extended years
back it's a pattern so tough day to be
the press secretary but it there is a
irony and the day NBC gets it wrong and
media CNN as you point out Laura's
regularly got it wrong blaming the press
secretary for getting something wrong it
was a interesting that today and we'll
go to Bradley on this and Saul
George Conway who's the husband of
Kellyanne Conway I've known George for
25 years this really smart lawyer he
decided to tweet out a I believe it was
a regulation there it is which
unfortunately yeah there it is yeah so
he says not considered not considered
the candidates personal funds and then
he you know recites the relevant part of
the statute and that was considered to
be interesting because of course he's
the husband of Kellyanne Conway and it
would lead people to believe that George
Conway another smart lawyer is saying he
is trying to influence or he was trying
to influence the election with this
Michael Cohen payment to me that seemed
like a huge leap Bradley and it was like
a head scratcher for me like I mean I
love George we're like why the heck he's
sending out that tweet I mean he doesn't
know the background on this and I guess
neither do any of us that's still being
developed yeah I mean one of the things
we've had for the last years is people
are always letting conclusions outrun
the you know the facts on the ground you
know the the statute does say install
mention this that the staff
basically says an expenditure campaign
expenditure is something for the purpose
of influencing a campaign but that has
to be considered in conjunction with
other definitions of the statute and
another part of the statute specifically
says what are not campaign expenditures
and camp things are not campaign
expenditures if they the obligation
would have existed irrespective of the
campaign
like I say like buying a new suit
getting a haircut or for some people I
suppose you know having to pay off
asking you a threat yeah or nuisance
suits all I want your reaction to that a
nuisance suit if it was a pattern of
conduct for this operation it's a huge
organization he's a big target as a
celebrity this probably could have been
done before well it's done before I have
no idea but if it was that goes the
effort the the intent issue it's a fact
question like I said eleven days before
the campaign it's gonna be a fact
question I the reason I think George I
don't know him but I'm gonna call him
George I feel like I know him the reason
why I think he sent that out is because
Giuliani said oh the president paid for
it bought for it with his personal funds
ergo for sure it's not a campaign
violation I think he's just pointing out
I got that it's really not it's not who
pays the funds he's not saying there's a
campaign violation he's just saying it's
not who pays the funds it's for the
purpose I think he's right all right
well maybe he's just saying I'm smarter
than you are and I'm no I'm sorry I'm
just teasing thanks to all of you